-Our next guest is
an Emmy-winning comedian
whose upcoming tour,
"Who's Ready to Laugh?",
kicks off September 10th
in Medford, Massachusetts,
at the Chevalier Theatre.
He also stars in "A.P. Bio,"
which returns to Peacock
for its fourth season
September 2nd.
Let's take a look.
-Ralph, this is insane!
Please cancel the uniforms.
-That is a no, I can't do,
alright? Look.
I was talking
to the superintendent
and she said one
of the biggest problems
in this district is bullying.
So I pointed out, "Well,
if everybody wore
the same thing,
less stuff to make fun of,"
you know?
Because it's harder to tell
when someone is...
dorky and who's...
poor.
-Mm.
-They're going to call it
the Durbin Anti-Bullying
Uniform Campaign.
Yay!
-Who will?
-Yay!
-Who's going to call it that?
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Patton Oswalt.
How are you, Patton?
-I'm great.
Good to be back, Seth.
-This is very exciting --
you're about to embark
on a tour.
Like all stand-ups,
I think you've been
on the shelf.
Are you so excited
to get back out?
-I am very, very excited.
I'm a little bit nervous.
It feels like maybe we're --
I hope we're not heading back
towards a shutdown.
I'm making my touring plans
in good faith.
But it almost feels like
we were so close
to getting into the club.
Like the doorman,
our group of friends
was kind of schmoozing him.
He's like, "I like these guys.
You know what?
Wait like ten minutes.
I'll wait for 20 people
to leave.
I'll get you guys in,"
and then,
just before we're there,
one of the members
of our group goes,
"Just let us in, [bleep]!"
-[ Laughs ]
-He's like, "You know what?
All of you, no."
Like that's how this second wave
of COVID feels like.
The Delta variant is our friend
saying, "Let us in, [bleep]."
-Yes. I think that is
a very good analogy.
And, you know, I think, you,
obviously, are in California,
California's had
a very tough time of it,
getting locked back down,
to some degree.
Certainly, things are
coming back into effect.
How do you view the way
your fellow Californians
have approached this pandemic?
-I mean, for the most part,
we've been good,
but, unfortunately,
California is home
to a lot of people on the very
far end of the health spectrum,
who are very much about,
"I care what goes into my body
and I don't feel like
this vaccine
is part of a paleo lifestyle."
So, whereas, you have people
in the Midwest saying,
[ Changes accent ]
"That needle's got
which poison in it,"
-[ Laughs ]
-they're weirdly aligned
with the yoga freaks going,
"You know, if we could all
just align our chakras
at the same time, the virus
would go to a different planet."
[ Laughter ]
So it's equally bad.
It's just
on a different wavelength.
-You know, again, we're talking
about how things are.
They did, at least, seem like
they were going back to normal,
but not necessarily
in a positive way.
There were some things
that changed that,
it maybe would've been better
if it stayed that way.
-Yes. Okay, and I remember this
very clearly.
Right when
the shutdown happened,
right when the
quarantine happened,
and I was one of them, saying,
"Well, cruise ships
and buffets are gone.
They're never coming back
after this,"
and I'm realizing
buffets are going to come back
with a vengeance
and they're going
to come back with this weird
like super patriot MAGA tinge
to them, going, you know --
[ Changes accent ]
"Are you one of those
left coast liberals
that needs a sneeze guard
over their clam chowder,
or are you able
to [bleep] your wife?"
[ Laughter ]
That's how they're going
to advertise buffets
from now on.
It's all going to have
this weird MAGA twist to them.
-Very excited about Season 4
of "A.P. Bio."
Principal Durbin, a perfect
character for Patton Oswalt.
But I also wanted to look back
at some really good photos
-[ Laughing ] Oh, God.
-of you from school growing up.
This is in line with, I think,
both how you present yourself
and maybe
how people see yourself.
Of course,
you were involved in D&D.
-Of course.
-Of the people that are
in this photo,
you are the most D&D person
in this photo.
-The most.
I am holding the original
hardback player's manual.
I look like I've just been
given Aerosmith tickets,
[ Laughter ]
I'm so happy in that photo.
I don't think I've ever
been that happy.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I could not be more nerded out.
I got the weird little glasses
and -- oh, my God. Mwah!
-Everything about it.
Like, yeah,
you feel like genuinely so happy
that they were like,
"You guys want
to get a picture?"
You're like, "Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
I want people to know this!"
-Of the whole group,
you can tell that I was the one
that ran over, went, "Hang on!"
And I grabbed my player's manual
to like hold it up like,
"I've got it!"
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I didn't know this,
but you would argue --
because this is you
doing something in college.
This is an athletic activity.
But you see this as a natural
throughline connected to D&D.
-Yes.
-Tell us what you're doing here.
-I was on the fencing team
my first two years of college.
That's me --
third from the left.
And, in my mind,
that was a straight line
from all the years of imagining
wielding a sword to,
"Okay, I'm at college and I
can actually wield a sword."
[ Laughter ]
And so there I was with my foil.
I tried for saber,
did not have the arm speed,
and then, by sophomore year,
I had discovered weed
and the Beastie Boys
and, in a weird way, that's also
part of the same trajectory.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah.
-You feel like,
look, I go to a lot
of fencing meets.
You never hear Beastie Boys
over the PA.
-No, you do not.
-I feel like those two
do not mesh well.
-And, actually,
now that I think of it,
there are some really good
Beastie Boys songs
that would be great
walkout songs for fencers,
now that I think I said it.
-100%.
-Yeah. "Looking
Down the Barrel of a Gun"
would be a great walkout song
as you unsheathe your sword
and they do that whole rolling.
That'd be amazing.
Off of "Paul's Boutique."
Great walkout song for fencers.
-If you're a young fencer
watching the show right now,
take Patton's word for it.
You have a podcast
with your lovely wife, Meredith.
-I have a podcast with my wife,
called "Did You Get My Text?"
And it's just so happens
-Oh, do we have her here?
-that my lovely wife
-Hi!
-is sitting right here!
-Hello!
Nice to see you, Meredith.
-Wait. Seth, thank you
for showing that picture
of Patton playing D&D.
-Oh, gotcha.
No, not that picture.
-Yeah, this one.
-Because I cannot tell you
how much more in love with him
that that makes me.
That is crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Are you at all concerned
that he's never seemed
that happy in your presence?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, that is the cutest
thing I've ever seen in my life.
It makes me substantially
more attracted to you.
I did not think that
that picture
would be catnip for hotties.
I had no idea.
-So, alright, so this, guys,
"Did You Get My Text?"
This is a podcast
about your relationship.
You might think this is about
a long-distance relationship
because it is about your
texting communication,
but that is absolutely
not the case.
-No. We are a married couple
who lives together
and I think,
like a lot of married couples
who've gotten a lot of feedback,
we are in the same house,
but we text each other all day.
-Yeah.
He's in his room.
I'm in my part of the house
and it's just easier
to text each other.
But we don't really ever
sit down and talk about it,
so the podcast sort of
is an opportunity for us
to sit down
and talk to each other.
Not just give a thumbs-up
on something he said,
but like communicate.
-"What was this?
Why did you send this
and what was this?"
-That's interesting.
My wife and I have talked
about the thumbs-up,
that sometimes that is not --
It seems like
a passive-aggressive approval,
that you would do the thumbs-up,
as opposed to writing,
"That sounds great."
-Yeah.
Or it also feels like,
"Okay, conversation's over.
[ Laughter ]
Like got it. Moving on."
-Right, yeah.
Which is also
passive-aggressive, you know?
-Yeah.
-Well, it's also because you --
I haven't given a physical
thumbs-up in a long time.
So if my wife said to me like,
you know,
"You want to have a dinner
with my friends tonight?"
And I did that,
I think she'd be like,
"You know, get over yourself."
[ Laughter ]
-And also, that would seem
beyond rude.
Someone gives you a proposal
and you just go, "Good."
[ Laughter ]
That'd be so awkward.
-The texting situation
has gotten a little --
-Oh, man.
-a little --
It's a lot because sometimes,
like the other night,
we were in bed together and our
backs were towards each other
and I was so comfortable
on my side.
-She had found
-I was like the perfect
-a perfect position...
-position, you know?
-...like, "Here I am."
And then he's like, "Oh,
I want to show you something,"
and I was like, "Ugh.
Can you just --"
I just got this great position.
-She did not want to turn over.
-Yeah, I didn't want
to turn over to look at it,
so I was like,
"Can you just text it to me?"
-So you were physically
touching and, yet,
you needed to receive a text?
-In bed back-to-back.
-And she had got the pillows
just how she wanted them
and I found this cool thing
I wanted her to look at.
And she said it with this
-I was laughing,
-laughing,
but also knowing how --
She goes, "You're going to need
to text that to me
because I will not lose
this position."
-I was so comfortable.
-I appreciate that.
And I actually do think
you did Patton a favor
because then it puts so much
less weight on the text
because, if you had to get
out of your position
and Patton was showing you
something stupid,
then how mad
you would've been at him.
-"That's not that good,
for me to turn around.
-You're right.
-It's not good enough."
-What if the text
hadn't lived up
to her losing this position?
Wow!
-Right.
-Yeah.
-That makes a lot of sense.
-I think you guys
have figured it out.
-[Both] Yeah.
-We really have.
-It's so lovely
to see both of you.
It's so nice to see your faces
and, hopefully, next time,
we'll see you in person.
The fourth season
of "A.P. Bio" premieres
on Peacock September 2nd
and the podcast
"Did You See My Text?"
releases new episodes
every Tuesday.
And one last time,
in case you're curious,
that is how happy he was
to take that picture.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."